the fourth move I want to consider is
Bishop to B5 check which I personally
think is one of the most accurate choice
and against this you already know what
to do yep C6 Pawn takes C6 Knight takes
C6 and now Black's idea is very simple
in the majority of the cases you want to
play Bishop to D6 protecting the pawn
followed up with Bishop to G4 pinning
down this KN and then depending on the
circumstances you can Castle on the king
side and later on throw your G Pawn up
to the
pole let's see how we can achieve all of
this well in the database D4 is by far
the most popular choice trying to get
the pawn back so we are going to play
Bishop to D6
defending there is a small trap here
guys that if you if your opponent think
that hang on I can win a peace with
D5 well guess what it is now white who
is going to lose the material after
Knight captures D5 as simply White Queen
cannot take this Knight due to this old
trick Bishop to B4 and nabbing the white
sweee so no that is right out of the
equation the second most popular choice
in this position is Queen to E2 check
and against this black should play
Bishop to
E6 which at first side looks like very
inaccurate as white can play the Moon
Knight to G5 and attack this
bishop but here comes another nasty
trick starting with Castle on the king
side and the point is you won't believe
this Knight captures E6 black plays
Queen to
B6 not only sacking the bishop but now
sacking The
Rook so what's the
point well here is the answer guys Rook
to E8 exploiting the fact that white
major pieces are on the eal so now by
force white has to take this rook and
after Knight takes E8 black has a queen
for the two Rooks which is generally
okay but because white is far behind in
development this is obviously better for
the
black well we get some forcing lines
Bishop takes C6 Queen takes C6 white has
to Castle and when black recaptured the
piece white has two
choices if he tried to defend the C Pawn
with
C3 black can also defend his Pawn with
G5
so this is not good for white and there
is a high-profile game in the database
continue with Bishop takes F4 where
black shows the power of His Queen by
first capturing this bishop and then
take on C2 which allow him to munch few
important pawns and at the end when
white double up the rook and create the
only threat he calmly defend this with
Knight to
D6 okay now the C3 Knight hanging so
white has to defend it but here comes
the winning blow B5 and the idea is very
obvious B4 dislodging the Knight and
then taking either of this
Pawn well indeed after the few moves
Black manage to win the game and get the
full
point
so then we come to the Top Choice Castle
on the king side and after this yep we
castle and when white plays the move C3
consolidate his Pawn
chain here comes the super surprise guys
if you look at the database Bishop to G4
has been exclusively played here however
I found this very interesting tricky
Line St starting with
F6 our idea is we really want to play G5
and attack white on the king
side well before we move on one
important thing I like to mention that
GM npom Nishi World Championship
Challenger and the leading expert of
this line confirms that this position is
slightly better for the black and as a
Kings Gambit player you should avoid
it so you can now understand the Venom
behind this wonderful
line okay let's see what is our overall
plan well the theory goes like this
Knight B2 D2 you play G5 grabbing every
single space on the quein side and
please note that the important factor in
this line is White's dark Square Bishop
always remain a passive creature thanks
to our wonderful paon
J now we are going to see a model game
that how we can put these things in the
practice in a feed game between two
grand Masters white choose the move
Bishop to D3 avoiding Black's Bishop to
F5 and threatening Knight to E4 so black
plays Rook to E8 covering that square
and after Knight to C4 black just calmly
retrieve the bishop back to
C7 okay Queen to C2 happen and black
plays Bishop to E6 an alternative
location and please pay attention guys
here comes the most important plan in
this line what really black wants to do
is he wants to maneuver this Knights to
this juicy E3 square and then launch the
kingside attack whereupon in majority of
the cases
white is clearly lacking the plan except
coming on the
quinide and this is exactly happening
the game white plays B4 black plays A6
and after
A4 what else but Rook to
C8 white continue his aggression on the
quein side with B5 but after Pawn taks
paon Tak and the Moon Knight to
E7 now you are going to see our idea
right in the
action Bishop to A3 finally that Bishop
has been Unleashed but too little too
late Knight to
D5 first Knight is ready to rock on on
E3
square and after Rook to E1 what
else the second brother comes right into
the mix with Knight to
G4 where it is nearly in impossible for
white to survive in these
positions white thought he can handle
this with Bishop to C1 and everything is
protected but what has been missed out
is the tactic strikes at the other end
of the side black delivered this nice
surprising package Bishop to A5 where he
has some clear threats of sacrifice on
C3 which unfortunately for white cannot
be
denied for example if you play Bishop to
D2 then black can simply take on C3 and
after some obvious sequence Bishop takes
C3 Rook takes C4 Bishop takes C4 and the
Moon Knight to
E3 it is black Who come out as a
complete advantageous position from this
line so that is the threat here guys and
white has to be very careful and
accordingly white tried the move Knight
catches A5 removing this dangerous
Bishop but after Queen takes A5 triple
attack white has to move C Pawn only to
find the root shock Knight to E3 Bishop
takes E3 and after Knight takes
E3 sadly enough black resigned the game
as Rook takes E3 and pawn takes E3 3
white is a clear exchange down for
absolutely no compensation at
all last but not least what to do
against the move Bishop to
C4 black can simply take on D5 however I
think C6 is more accurate Choice here
consistent with our approach so that
after Pawn takes C6
Knight takes
C6 it doesn't matter whether white
continue with D4 or Castle both leads to
the same path for example Castle on the
king side we play Bishop to C5 check
King to H1 Castle on the king side and
after C3 which has a clear intention of
D4 once again if you look at the
database Bishop to G E4 exclusively
played here but if you have remember of
a l approach you will easily find the
next Black
move yep
at6 G5 is a on agenda and after D4
Bishop to
D6 Knight B to D2 and this time we can
take the benefit of this position by
first playing Bishop to F5 so that it
can influence some more active
squares okay once again I'm going to
show you a model game between two grand
Masters where white continue with Knight
to H4 attacking this bishop and after
Bishop to H7 he just played Bishop to B3
trying to exchange via C2
Square well no priz for guessing Black's
next obvious response that is G5 this so
old story this time we are attacking the
night and after Knight 2 F3 black indeed
continue with his routine business
namely Rook to E8 and then launching
this two nights on the juc E3
Square okay white plays Knight to C4
Bishop to C7 and now Bishop to
C2 but I think it is black who is more
than happy with this Exchange as White's
attacker is gone and now before doing
the night dancing
maneuver black even take the space on
the quein side with B5 Knight A3 and A6
so that after Bishop to D2 he just
connect the Rook with Queen to D7 before
doing the very important Knight
Manu okay Rook e happened black plays
Rook to
C8 and seeing that black knight or the
pawn coming on the king side white
played the move H3 stopping our one of
the night coming on the G4 square and
this question may be comes to your mind
now
watch well there is a saying in chess
every single pawn move create weakness
and this time around one can easily see
that white has severely weakened the G3
Square so the natural response is Knight
to H5 and then putting the knife on yet
another important
Square well the game finished very
quickly white plays King to G1 and after
Knight to G3 first is exchange one pair
of the rook and then play Rook to
E1 but with the space on the king side I
think this exchanges only helps the
black as after Queen to
E6 it is black who get the Open fall and
maybe white thought that I can hold on
to this position with more exchanges
Bishop takes Pawn
takes and now B3 protecting the A2 but
doing so he allowed black pieces to
infiltrate on his territory with Queen
check King to F1 and now Bishop to F4
where upon position looks very scary for
the
white okay he tried to activate his bad
Knight with Knight to B1 and exactly
here black find the elegant tactical
blow namely
B4 ripping apart the pawn structure as
white cannot play C4 due to D4 Pawn
hangs so in the game white choose C
captures B4 but that simply allows
Knight takes B4 attacking the queen
queen to E2 has been played but this
move simply loses the pawn after the
following sequence Queen check Queen to
E1 and now Knight takes A2 so that once
the queen get exchanged one can easily
see the domination of black and without
any words words you just like to see the
engine Evolution here which clearly says
that it is black who has a completely
winning Advantage from
here that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high-profile trickiest line
against the king's Gambit which not only
contains lot of tricks and traps but if
you go go through them properly you will
find that white is really struggling in
the majority of the
cases you can definitely use this as a
complete surprise weapon in the
tournament practice and get some quick
wins against the king's
Gambit well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and I will see you in my next
episode very
soon bye and take
care